hello everybody shut up nurse my name is
markiplier and my I I am here to take
this somewhat shut up I'm going to get
off [ __ ] shut up I said shut up
go away go away alright thank you
alright so anyway my name is markiplier
and I'm here to get this underway I am
here to save Bob's life and I'm going to
do it to the best of my ability I'm
going to do this incredibly cuz I am a
super talented surgeon man come here
come here come hither I give it to my
come hither look and it just comes on
over so what we need to do in order to
be able to do this correctly is we need
to be able to remove all of these
intestines first so to do that you need
to very carefully cut them out all of
them every of them until they're nice
and limber and then you can go about
your business I probably should get
those ribs out of the way all right
whatever all secondary details the more
important thing is you get these out of
here because they do not need to be here
obviously you do not need any of this to
survive normal human being
can be just fine without pretty much any
of this so slice it up get it out of
there I'm beginning to think that this
is not the appropriate tool to do this
because he's bleeding out pretty
severely what the hell what's he
bleeding so much
give it gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme
give it give it give it
Chabot thank you jab jab jab jab jab jab
jab jab it I said jabu jabu can you jab
him or what are you gonna are you gonna
just still let him bleed at one per
second you shut of a [ __ ]
jab him alright I guess that's good
enough losing more blood from jabbing
him than anything all right set that
down nice and gently
alright let's see what we can pull out
if anything alright
see
damnit what the hell's going on this is
ridiculousness he's not even partially
severed man am I am I a bad doctor a
question Maya I questioned my own
practices here am I am I really a bad
doctor
the lasers got to be good I mean I can
only assume that it's relatively okay
it's slicing things out of this patient
I mean is it it I don't even know where
to cut I don't even know what I'm doing
is this even cut incorrectly I think
maybe it does that seem like it's
cutting anything okay they're finally
the sigmoid colon has been or the
descending colon has been severed now I
just got it ah there we go finally Oh
God
stop the blade a he's gonna die I'm
really trying here KITT no no no no no
no no do not cover up my syringe I'm
really trying here a bride I really
dragged I I'm trying it I kill him
faster than ever
dammit okay now but now I know where to
cut that's the most important thing
knowing where to cut is half the battle
okay so let's try the skin is there a
what you like
turn the power of the laser down so it
doesn't absolutely destroy him
come on give me that okay so we're gonna
do is I know where to cut cuz I can see
I can oh I can see the incisions now
okay
so just cut right along those lines okay
that one's severed cut this one right on
that line that one's severed cut that
right on that line wait is that the line
or is that the line where's the line
where's the cutting line where do you
cut
at you bastard you're just trying to
make me look bad you're just trying to
make me look bad
what the hell damn it what the hell this
is such bull this I swear it is like
such bull
okay oh you son of a [ __ ] see I I don't
I
son of a [ __ ] I don't want a scalpel
who would use a scalpel in this
situation
yes give give give give jab jab jab
heal him heal him tap them right in the
bones
yes that's good okay let's see if we
could pull something out Jesus are you
your son of the [ __ ] what is holding
you in there is it the ribs oh if it's
the ribs I'm gonna be so angry it is it
is the ribs isn't it son of a [ __ ] let
me write a note here to myself god I
can't even reach Mike Patton verge okay
whatever whatever whatever whatever
we'll make do as best we can
ah get the ribs out of there turn her
first her first car and then her purse
Kurt can't get good Gibbs Gibbs Gibbs
that's cute her purse key got it not
stabbed and if I don't save Emma so
myself whole doctor just so handsome and
smart sad nurse I know I'm handsome I'm
the most handsome a doctor in here
ergo I must be the best oh yeah okay
that must have been one was blocking it
because now things seem a bit more
jiggly I didn't know that I was supposed
to get the ribs out of there first what
am i grabbing on to what's going on what
is going on
what about doing hey yeah yeah that's
what I thought I'm not even doing that
but this is what I think are you Bob and
your damn intestines and your damn the
organs and damn you to hell I'm gonna
save you whether you like it or not it's
saving you might mean killing you I'm
not entirely sure about that okay now
let's see here we get something nope
nope the ribs were of no recourse to the
entire thing come here come here come
here
coming coming gotcha all right I'm gonna
cut you into fast haul and then I'm
going to cut your how do I I cut this
before
I swear I'm trying to make long cuts
slicing laser motions in this thing
place where the damn thing will not cut
where do you cut this cut not news there
oh you cut at the way at the base why
would you do that he's bleeding now hit
the damn trench what what the hell
gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme
again jab him Jotham Jotham kill him
kill him he's almost out of blood Jesus
hey l'm good golly Miss Molly okay all
right so we finally managed to get one
piece of intestine out of there
Wow the large intestines are Dow out and
I bet the small intestines aren't even
close to out I'm the greatest doctor
ever ah
didn't see that coming that idiot I need
to cut some more
come here lazy come here
ah dog dog don't cut me come come here
is there a way to kill myself can I kill
myself and all the pain come I my watch
off and nothing up just yep here come
here there we go
okay now oh man this rough
didn't even seem to be cutting him
what's going on oh my fingers blocking
the laser you gotta be kidding me
doctor don't be a murdering pattern of
spiral miss I think I see little bitty
red points like right up there but I
can't quite get to it it's like very
closed in at this point I'm just
experimenting at this point I'm just
trying to get this to cut off I think I
severed it but there we go there we go
geez maybe I should try this with a
scalpel because my god okay the doctors
in the house doctor I believe in you
shut up nurse I know I believe in me I
don't need you to believe in me either
okay okay blue League bases come on
Heather
there we go okay now I'm gonna try this
oh so delicately
why is there a spoon here I can't cut
with a spoon can I can I cut with us oh
yeah just really scrape it up in there
maybe I'll find out that the spoon is
like the secret mega awesome tool I now
operate with spoon I'm going to spawn
your intestines out and then get
everything nice and soft in there I
don't think this is doing anything
however I will not stop I am such a
successful doctor with spoon shut up Bob
you think you know what is best in
Nicaragua which we talk with this accent
we only operate with spoon you think you
know what is best
you do not Bob you do not spoon is
greatest tool in whadya we only have
spoon Olivia we don't even have a spoon
or potato one day long ago we had many
spoon and potato now we have nothing
such is life
now we try wash oh not this again
oh god okay we're gonna try to double
scalpel him oh this is good everything's
so bright and colorful let's just try to
hey that actually works it cut like a
dream or maybe I loosened it up with
spoon I loosened with spoon and it just
suddenly worked I can't see any tin but
I think I cut it I think I'm not sure I
cut it this is great at cutting who
would have thought a scalpel is
incredible at cutting this is it this is
marvelous I don't think I quite got the
the the large intestines out so I got a
cut towards the base I think I can't see
what I'm doing but I think I think I got
it and I think I got it I can't see [ __ ]
but here we go
work butanone let the damn scalpel would
be great at cutting oh man can I get
this trippy mode out if I like hit
myself with the other syringe will it
will it not be as crazy hey let me try
to stab myself with the other syringe
here come on come on turn it off turn it
off they're all it worked
Wow I did not think that was actually
gonna work okay man I'm like the best
doctor in the world and if you actually
use proper surgical tools things go a
little better get it off like a dream
like a dream
beautiful painful come on get out of
here
that's the duodenum or the ileum is that
the ileum ordered one I can't tell all
these things look the same I love this
girl
oh my finger stuck what the hell okay
pick up your other couple not the pad
don't pick up that pad you douche
getting angry there we go
okay what they'll still need to I don't
need to cut anything I don't let's not
put that on bad
he's put that over there and let's get
the rest of this out of here I didn't
even realize that this was gone
haha I left scalpel in here ha ha that's
so silly
what that what are the kidneys doing way
up there by the stomach
that's not where kidneys supposed to be
I should know I am great doctor from
Nicaragua
I'm from the Russian part of Nicaragua
but everybody no no all right did you
get these damned ribs out of here
they're in the way
Dam dam dam is these it's to seem a
little high up I don't know I don't know
if it's quite correct but Anna they
should know best right I mean other
doctors labelled it they know it's best
right they would know they know what's
best
aim hit there we go good enough he's
bleeding little bits but that's good
little blood for good for everybody
too much blood just as bad toss that out
and just let it rip this whatever this
bread goopy thing is I still don't know
I've seen I've seen many dead bodies
I've never seen this before
answer come on give me let me get a good
grip on it I just need to get it nice
nice nice
I need my spoon where is spoon I miss
having spoon spoon it's great massage
the liver a sergeant I mean massage beef
a red thing I do not know what is oh
come on I guess I'll have to use a
scalpel fine fine
if you really want me to okay twice why
see slice slice slice out of there
I'll get this stomach while I'm at it I
guess I'll get the kidneys too there we
go one gun other gun oh those kidneys
gallant those good those definitely need
to come out oh come on don't don't don't
mess with me here okay and did I get
that yep got it okay let's stop the
bleeding quickly quickly quickly
money look like Bono
we click no hahaha or you not mess with
me now I am on verge of victory
we are almost close to a great victory
stab okay good good good good good good
we're actually see this is what happens
when I actually try I actually do
succeed good get the south of here oh
you still attached not for long oh there
we go use this Bob you see this this is
what drunk minecraft does to you rip
your liver out and rubs it all over your
face does it feel good Bob does that
feel good does that feel good Bob how
would you like your liver done I put it
right by the laser for cooking later
okay all right so anyway these kidneys
are done set the gallbladder man they're
pretty anatomically correct in here come
on oh gotta get that kidney out of there
that's got to come out what is this oh
that's the stomach don't need it ha ha
ha don't cry to get back in their
stomach you're running away from me
you're running away from great Nicaragua
latvian doctor hey
come on what the hell get out of there
get out of there give me the damn kidney
damn I don't want the gallbladder
what the hell give me the damn kidney I
need my spoon where is spoon it's
pudding this out is that still attached
actually oh that's still attached isn't
it uh okay well that would explain a lot
where's my good scalpel where's my good
scalpel well this isn't gonna help me in
that configuration but whatever all
right come here come here coming oh
don't tell me I've run out of scalpels I
will not lose this at the last second
and that's not how you hold a damn oh
wait they're playing scalpers right
there well anyway that's how you hold a
damn scalpel oh all right
things are just things are really really
good damn it
[ __ ] flip you son of a [ __ ] okay
this will have to do oh this I just
slice it off oh man god damn I'm so
angry girl that was infuriating that was
beyond infuriating that was the worst
give me the gimmick give me the damn
kidney give me the damn it's detached
now I know this I know this for a fact
just give me the kidney my god I'm so
angry this son of a [ __ ] you gotta be
joking me this is unbelievable and as a
radicular where's my spoon give me my
damn spoon [ __ ] how can I get this out
what the hell I'm not gonna go in with a
power tool not now and he's bleeding god
damn it this is ridiculous
this is absolutely ridiculous how can I
not get this right [ __ ] here
Jesus I'm gonna kill myself yeah
damn kidney out what the hell is
stopping me I love what the hell Jesus
Christ what the hell oh my god I'm
losing my mind I cannot get this [ __ ]
kidney out but scoop it out with this
you gotta be joking me this is the worst
just get out of there I'm so angry
there's an unbelievable scoop your
[ __ ] kidney out I know you're
detached get out of there Oh like buried
in your [ __ ] kidney bean get out it
moved it moved it moved it finally
[ __ ] moved get out get out get out
get we got it we got it we got it to
move okay just grab it just [ __ ] grab
it oh my god this is unbelievable
this is on [ __ ] believable you gotta
be joking me I'm busting that last bit
of rib I bet that last oh do not lose my
hammer do not lose my hammer do not lose
my [ __ ] hammer you son of a [ __ ]
okay get over here seriously just
cooperate cooperate with a be nice be
nice to me I'm not God Janet stop going
that way [ __ ] you know what [ __ ] I just
gotta get that last bit of rib out I bet
that's it Oh nope there we go got that
last bit of rib out oh man so I'm so
unbelievably aggravated right now what
the hell I can't get this [ __ ] kidney
out oh my god I keep driving into a
corner I keep driving it into a corner
how the hell am I supposed to get this
frickin kidney gimme gimme gimme gimme
gimme
gimme what the hell do I have why why
why can't I grab you why can't I grab
you get out I have you I swear I have
you what the hell I'm so sad everything
in my life is just pain
what the hell Jesus get out of there I'm
so uh this is unbelievable
why why do you do this to me why I'm a
nice guy I try I try hard in life don't
grab the edge of the table grab the
[ __ ] scalpel because apparently this
is not wanting to get out so there's
another spoon I see a spoon I'm gonna
get it out with the [ __ ] spoon give
me that goddamn spoon okay I have a
spoon get get the rest of that off there
no I have the pliers I have the ER the
tweezers give me the spoon I'm gonna
spoon this son of a [ __ ] out of there
do not grab the colon oh my god give me
the spoon give me the spoon get out no
my spoon get out of there this is the
one time where I actually want a spoon
it's facing the wrong way but whatever
I'll just make do with what I have now
spoon it out of there just spoon it out
spoon it out I can't believe this
this is unbelievable they they're
[ __ ] unbelievable this is the worst
this is horrifying I can't even
understand this this doesn't make any
damn sense what the [ __ ] it's detached I
know it is because it's moved around
before but this [ __ ] thing I swear to
god what the [ __ ] it's moving it's okay
it's move don't move back up move down I
swear I'm gonna kill myself okay get out
of the corner can you just get into some
sort of semblance of the sin no don't go
back okay stay right [ __ ] there do
not [ __ ] move
god dammit [ __ ] finally Mother of God
what gosh
my god I hope the I hope the developers
of its game saw that and saw how
unbelievably [ __ ] that was that was
just [ __ ] [ __ ] oh my god are you
[ __ ] joking me
I am so this is like did I not do it
Oh what you got you will not there we go
you've got to be kidding me Oh I'm so
unbelievably angry I'm gonna punch like
ten kittens in the face I'm so angry you
can see the veins in my neck bulging out
of me
shut up nurse I cannot believe how
infuriating that was that was just
beyond everything I've played rage games
I've played horrifying games I played
the worst games in existence and holy
[ __ ] that was awful my god I am so angry
I am so angry I want to strangle a tree
I want to grab it by its leafy neck and
just drain the life I want to watch as
every leaf on that tree fades to brown
that's a struggle until it dies girl hug
yeah I need I need to punch something I
am so angry so I'm gonna have an
aneurysm I'm so angry
alright so anyway thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
ba-bye
Oh